with great power comes great
responsibility what other roles has tom
holland been hiding from us
tom holland came crashing into the world
of hollywood
the moment it was announced he'd be
playing the role of spider-man in the
marvel cinematic universe
but playing peter parker wasn't his
first and definitely isn't the last role
he's taken on
since we saw him zip up his super suit
what if we told you there are plenty of
other films tom holland starred in and
you probably didn't even realize it
we're not just talking unknown
b-rated movies either did you know he
acted in the disney movie onward and did
we mention that the avengers wasn't the
first film he starred in alongside chris
hemsworth
get ready because in this video we're
uncovering all of tom holland's most
shocking acting jobs now everyone's
going to get to see me be a dog
you most likely know tom holland because
of his portrayal of spider-man but do
you
actually know how many times he's
reprised the role he of course was the
star of spider-man homecoming and
spider-man far from home
and is set to release a third movie but
he's also appeared in tons of spider-man
shorts
you can catch him in science fair and
peter's to-do list it's no wonder that
playing spider-man has been his most
favorite role yet
spider-man far from home was like the
first time i got to play a character who
was exploring so many different crazy
things
believe it or not tom holland's
spider-man films weren't
actually his big break his first
appearance in the marvel films happened
during his cameo in captain america
civil war
this is where he first got to figure out
how he wanted to bring his version of
the character to life
it was it was difficult to me to find a
new spin on the character
imagine having to be compared to both
toby mcguire
and andrew garfield of course if tom
holland as spider-man is featured in the
mcu
they wouldn't dare exclude him from the
avengers movies
he played a key role in avengers
infinity war
and avengers end game and despite tom
having a tendency to reveal pretty big
spoilers about the films
the other heroes have had nothing but
kind words to share about him
stepping away from his hero days after
his big break is spider-man
he's gone on to land so many other roles
including a pretty awesome gig with
disney's pixar he voiced ian lightfoot
in the disney plus movie
alongside his avengers co-star chris
pratt it might be a bit of a shock that
tom has dabbled in voice acting but
starring in a pixar movie
has always been one of his dreams get
down
on some cake that's not something anyone
says
speaking of voice acting he also took on
the role of walter in the film spies in
disguise
it was actually his first role coming
out of the spider-man films
he got to work alongside the one and
only fresh prince
also known as will smith he just
couldn't turn down the role when he
found out how positive
his character walter was meant to be
i'll always have your backlash
it's what it means to be a team 2020 has
been no exception when it comes to tom
continuing to release projects his
newest role was in the netflix film
the devil all the time where he plays a
character named arvin
but tom had to step out of his comfort
zone a little bit with this
psychological thriller he told vanity
fair he was really nervous and scared
during his first day on set
because he didn't know whether he'd be
able to play this type of character
if you've ever wanted to see tom in a
drastically different role from
spider-man
this is definitely the movie for you
i've been watching your every move for
the last couple weeks
tom's next film isn't going to be
released until 2021 but it actually
first shot all the way back in 2017. tom
plays the character todd alongside star
wars legend daisy ridley's character
viola in this dystopian world but
because the two actors became
super famous super fast they had to
reschedule their reshoots
all the way into 2019. it'll be
interesting to see a 21 year old tom
holland
take the screen when we've already
watched him grow up before our eyes
if you want to see the very beginnings
of tom holland's career
checking out his work is isaac and how i
live now
is probably a good idea this was one of
tom's first acting roles back in 2013.
he starred alongside sercia ronan in a
war-ridden world where their only hope
was love dramatic cool
come on let's go before he booked the
role of spider-man in captain america
civil war
tom thought his film in the heart of the
sea would be his big break
who could blame him he was cast
alongside huge actors like chris
hemsworth and brendan gleeson
he ironically used to beg chris to give
him all the details on thor
who knew that just a couple of months
later he'd be announced as one of the
most popular superheroes of all time
don't tell that me all right spider-man
pilgrimage was one of the last films tom
holland released before his life
changed forever he played brother
dyramid also known as the novice
in this 13th century film that followed
monks and a very sacred relic
the movie didn't receive the greatest
ratings and reviews but he had
spider-man to make up for it right after
hey could you hold this for a second
thanks
it's almost as if the universe really
wanted tom to work with the iconic
avengers squad
even outside of the marvel films not
only has he worked with chris hemsworth
and chris pratt he's also worked
alongside benedict cumberbatch
they both starred in the film the
current war where tom played a character
named samuel
what do you think is it fate or do they
just really enjoy
working with one another if the bulbs
are a battle
then nail them on the dynamos we can't
in 2016 he helped bring the story of
1920s real-life british explorer
major fawcett to the screen he took on
the role of jack fawcett his son
it's really interesting to see tom
holland take on all of these different
roles even before he came famous
can we get a versatility who is to say
it will not happen again
it could mother we all know how
embarrassing it can be to look back at
some of our projects from earlier life
but in tom holland's case
his beginnings are just as iconic as
where he is today
the first movie he ever filmed was
called the impossible and it was
released
all the way back in 2012. he played
lucas who was part of a family who
battles through a ginormous tsunami
on vacation in thailand what's your name
okay so this wasn't his biggest role but
it's still worth the mention
he got a little taste of the voice
acting life for his small role in the
movie lock
he played the son of the main character
eddie his voice is featured in the phone
calls eddie has with him
dad it's so embarrassing um
yeah what did you say about coming home
edge of winter was entirely different
for tom holland
it was the first movie he released after
becoming internationally known and
basically a household name he played
bradley baker one of two brothers who
realized their dad may not be who they
think he is
this movie also had an impact on tom
personally
it was the first film he ever shot alone
without his parents
he flew to canada by himself for months
to film
sure you don't want me to take over nah
i'm good i'm fine
tom had a very non-traditional role in a
monster calls
in fact if you watched the film you
wouldn't even realize he had
any part in it he acted as the stand-in
for a monster that was later added to
the film
using cgi would you be able to tell this
was tom
we really got to see the bromance of tom
holland and robert downey jr flourish in
this movie
the two reunited after the avengers for
the film doolittle while robert took on
the main role of dr doolittle himself
tom voiced the character jib he's
basically little sidekick
how fitting you need to stay behind and
guard the queen stand back everyone
before tom holland could even hit the
big screen he started on stage he was
recruited
after an agent spotted his amazing
dancing at a local recital he spent
months training for the role
and eventually took the lead as young
billy elliot his training for the show
is the reason why he can do so many of
his own stunts and the reason why we got
the masterpiece that is his lip sync
battle with zendaya
wolf hall is one of the only series that
tom holland ever actually worked in
he was featured in five episodes and
played gregory in this british drama
series
you might recognize his co-star thomas
brody sangster
in this show who also worked in maze
runner
lastly this small role was released
right before he got his ticket into
hollywood
it was for the short film tweet and he
played a character named tom
look at that growth i've like grown a
lot as an actor through the years and
i've played lots of different types of
roles
there's no doubt that tom holland has
and probably will continue to shock us
with the talent he brings to the screen
but have you ever
overlooked any of his roles did you have
any idea that he dabbled in the world of
voice acting we can't wait to hear from
you in the comments section below
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button so you never miss out on another
video from the things
thanks for watching
you